>> Chris: MARK MEREDITH
REPORTING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE,
MARK, THANKS FOR THAT.
JOINING US NOW, TREASURY
SECRETARY STEPHEN MANOJ AND,
WHO’S A MEMBER OF THE
PRESIDENT ’S CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE.
MR. SECRETARY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
TALKED OPENLY YESTERDAY ABOUT A
POSSIBLE QUARANTINE OF THE
NEW YORK STATE AREA.
WHY DID YOU FIRST CONSIDER IT
AND WHY IS THE ADDED THREE IF
YOU DECIDE NOT TO GO AHEAD WITH
A?
SPEECH OF THE PRESIDENT DID VERY
SERIOUSLY CONSIDER IT.
THE TASK FORCE MET YESTERDAY
WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT.
IT WAS THE UNANIMOUS DECISION --
THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
TASK FORCE TO GO FORWARD WITH
THE ADVISORY.
THE VICE PRESIDENT, MYSELF,
MARK MEADOWS, AND OTHERS MET
WITH THE PRESIDENT YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON AND HE DECIDED TO GO
FORWARD WITH THE RECOMMENDATION.
>> Chris: WHAT WAS IT THAT
MADE HIM THINK A QUARANTINE
MIGHT BE NECESSARY, AND AGAIN,
WHY DID HE DECIDE NOT TO DO IT?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: I THINK
THE PRESIDENT WANTED TO CONSIDER
ALL THE OPTIONS.
HE WAS OPTICALLY CONCERNED WHAT
WAS GOING ON WITH NEW YORK.
HE SPOKE TO THE TASK FORCE, HE
SPOKE TO THE GOVERNORS THAT HE
WAS COMFORTABLE THAT PEOPLE
WOULD TAKE THIS ADVISORY VERY
SERIOUSLY AND WOULD NOT TRAVEL.
>> Chris: THE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE, OF WHICH ARE A
MEMBER, IS COMING UP WITH NEW
GUIDELINES, HOW TO STOP THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS GUIDELINES.
HERE’S WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
THIS WEEK ABOUT WHAT HE’D LIKE
TO SEE.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THE
COUNTRY OPENED UP AND JUST
RARING TO GO BY EASTER.
>> Chris: AS TREASURY
SECRETARY, DO YOU THINK THAT’S
REALISTIC?
TO OPEN UP PARTS OF THE COUNTRY,
TO OPEN UP PARTS OF THE ECONOMY
AS SOON AS TWO WEEKS FROM TODAY,
WHICH WILL BE EASTER?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: I’M
GOING TO LEAVE THAT DECISION TO
THE MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS AND
THE PRESIDENT.
AT MY FULL-TIME FOCUS RIGHT NOW
IS WE COULDN’T BE MORE PLEASED
THAT THE SENATE AND HOUSE
REACTED VERY QUICKLY, SIGNED AN
ENORMOUS PACKAGE TO SUPPORT U.S.
WORKERS IN THE ECONOMY, THE
PRESIDENT SIGNED INTO LAW AND MY
FULL-TIME FOCUS IS DELIVERING ON
THAT AND LET ME JUST SAY, THE
SPA IS WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE TREASURY.
WE EXPECT TO HAVE A PROGRAM UP
ON FRIDAY THAT WILL BE UP AND
RUNNING THAT WILL COVER HALF OF
THE PRIVATE WORKFORCE.
I ENCOURAGE ALL SMALL BUSINESSES
TO TAKE OUT THESE LOANS BECAUSE
IF YOU GO AND HIRE BACK YOUR
WORKERS FOR EIGHT WEEKS, YOU
WILL HAVE A FORGIVABLE LOAN AND
THE GOVERNMENT WILL PAY FOR
THAT.
SO AGAIN, IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR US THAT WORKERS ARE
PROTECTED AND THIS IS A MAJOR
PART OF THE PACKAGE.
>> Chris: MR. SECRETARY, I’M
GOING TO GET TO THAT PACKAGE IN
A MOMENT BUT I WANT TO PRESS ON
THIS ISSUE OF PERHAPS CHANGING
THE GUIDELINES, BECAUSE NOT ONLY
HAS A LOT OF HEALTH
IMPLICATIONS, IT ALSO HAS A LOT
OF ECONOMIC IMPLICATIONS.
THERE’S BEEN A LOT OF PUSHBACK
IN PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS ABOUT
THE IDEA OF REOPENING PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY WHERE THERE IS A
LOWER INCIDENCE OF THE VIRUS,
OPENING THEM UP PERHAPS WITHIN
TWO WEEKS.
OUR VERY NEXT GUEST, DR. TOM
INGLESBY, HEAD OF THE
JOHNS HOPKINS CENTER FOR HEALTH
SECURITY SAYS THIS DISEASE WILL
NOT RESPECT STATE QUARTERS TO
BORDERS AND CITY BORDERS AND
WILL MOVE AROUND THIS COUNTRY
JUST LIKE IT’S MOVED AROUND THE
WORLD.
SO THE QUESTION IS, IF THE VIRUS
SPREAD FROM CHINA TO ITALY,
CAN’T IT SPREAD FROM CHICAGO TO
IOWA AND IF WE WERE TO OPEN --
REOPEN PARTS OF THE COUNTRY TOO
SOON, WOULDN’T THAT BE THE WORST
THING FOR THE ECONOMY IF WE SEE
THE VIRUS SPREADING INTO MORE
AREAS?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: CHRIS, I
CAN ASSURE YOU THE PRESIDENT’S
NUMBER ONE OBJECTIVE IS THE
HEALTH OF THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
AND PROTECTING THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC AND WE ARE GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING TO SUPPORT THE
ECONOMY.
THE TASK FORCE WILL BE REVIEWING
IT, BE DISCUSSING IT WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
HASN’T BEEN ANY RECOMMENDATION
MADE YET, SO LET ME JUST
EMPHASIZE, THE PRESIDENT WANTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE KILL THE
VIRUS AGREED THROUGH IT QUICKLY
IN THE MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS ARE
WORKING ON THAT AND WHAT WE DO
THAT WE HAVE AND AND A GIGANTIC
ECONOMIC PROGRAM TO SUPPORT
AMERICAN WORKERS AND AMERICAN
BUSINESS.
>> Chris: LET’S GET TO THAT.
YOU ARE THE KEY ADMINISTRATION
FIGURE NEGOTIATING THAT
$2 TRILLION -- SOME CALL IT
RELIEF BILL, SOME CALL THE
STIMULUS BILL.
ONE PART OF THAT IS
$500 BILLION, HALF A TRILLION TO
HELP DEAL WITH VARIOUS BIG
CORPORATIONS.
HOW MUCH DISCRETION TO YOU AND
THE PRESIDENT HAVE IN DECIDING
WHO TO GIVE THAT $500 BILLION TO
TO?
WHICH CORPORATIONS AND UNDER
WHAT TERMS?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: THERE’S
TWO PARTS TO THIS PROGRAM.
THERE IS APPROXIMATELY
$50 BILLION THAT WE CAN MAKE
DIRECT TREASURY LOANS THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO THE PRESIDENT AND MY
APPROVAL.
THOSE ARE SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED
FOR THE AIRLINE BUSINESS AND FOR
THE CARGO BUSINESS, WHICH WERE
NATIONAL SECURITY CONCERNS.
AND ALSO GIVE US POSSIBILITY OF
THEIR OTHER NATIONAL SECURITY
COMPANIES AND LET ME BE CLEAR,
TAXPAYERS WILL BE FULLY
COMPENSATED FOR THOSE LOANS.
THE OTHER PART OF THE PACKAGE IS
FOR US TO WORK WITH THE
FEDERAL RESERVE.
I THINK YOU KNOW CHAIRMAN
JAY POWELL AND I NOW SPEAK
MULTIPLE TIMES A DAY ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
THE 13-3 WAS THE PACKAGE THAT
EXISTED UNDER FEDERAL RESERVE
ACT.
THE FEDERAL RESERVE HAS THE
ABILITY TO MAKE BROAD-BASED
LENDING PROGRAMS AVAILABLE.
ONCE THE FED REQUESTS THOSE
ACTIONS, THEY COME TO ME, I HAVE
TO APPROVE THEM.
AS TREASURY SECRETARY.
AND IN MANY CASES I CONTRIBUTE
CAPITAL TO SUPPORT THAT IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE PRESIDENT.
SO THESE ARE VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS.
WE THINK THEY CAN PROVIDE ABOUT
$4 TRILLION OF LIQUIDITY TO THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY.
AGAIN, WE EXPECT WE WILL GET
PAID BACK ON THESE LOANS.
THESE ARE TEMPORARY SUPPORT FOR
THE AMERICAN ECONOMY THAT’S VERY
CRITICAL AND WE’VE ALREADY
ROLLED OUT MANY OF THESE
ALREADY.
>> Chris: ONE OF THE BIG
STICKING POINTS WHEN YOU ARE
NEGOTIATING WITH DEMOCRATS IN
THE SENATE AS THEY WANTED AN
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO OVERSEE THE
BIG LOANS, THE BIG GRANTS TO BIG
CORPORATIONS AND JUST TWO HOURS
AFTER THE PRESIDENT SIGNED THE
$2 TRILLION BILL, HE PUT OUT A
SIGNING STATEMENT SAYING THAT HE
WILL ONLY ALLOW THAT
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO REPORT TO
CONGRESS UNDER "PRESIDENTIAL
SUPERVISION," SO DIDN’T THAT
BASICALLY VIOLATE THE DEAL YOU
MADE WITH THE DEMOCRATS IN THE
SENATE?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: I DON’T
THINK THAT’S THE CASE, CHRIS.
HIS CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES.
AGAIN, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE FULL
TRANSPARENCY THE WAY THIS WORKS,
HAVE FULL TRANSPARENCY IN
REPORTING, WHAT WE ARE DOING TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
WE ALSO HAVE A BIPARTISAN
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE THAT WILL
REVIEW OUR ACTIONS.
WE ARE FULLY COMFORTABLE THAT
WHATEVER WE DO WE WANT FULL
TRANSPARENCY AND WE ARE VERY
CAREFUL IN WHAT WE’RE DOING
ABOUT SUPPORTING AMERICAN
WORKERS IN THE AMERICAN ECONOMY.
>> Chris: SO DIRECTLY, WILL
THEY INSPECTOR GENERAL THAT WAS
PROVIDED FOR IN THIS BILL BE
ALLOWED TO TESTIFY REPORT TO
CONGRESS?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: CHRIS,
I’M GOING TO LEAVE THAT TO THE
LAWYERS.
MY FULL-TIME OBJECTIVE RIGHT NOW
IS TO MAKE SURE THIS
ADMINISTRATION DOES EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO GET THIS MONEY INTO
THE ECONOMY QUICKLY.
AT THE COMBINATION OF SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE THIS WEEK AND LET ME
JUST BE CLEAR, THIS IS NOT JUST
NORMAL SPA LENDERS.
ANY FDIC’S BANK, ANY CREDIT
UNION, THEY WILL BE AUTHORIZED
TO MAKE THESE LOANS SUBJECT TO
CERTAIN APPROVALS.
WE WILL ALSO HAVE DIRECT DEPOSIT
INTO PEOPLE’S ACCOUNTS WITHIN
THREE WEEKS SO THEY HAVE CHECKS.
THESE ARE BRIDGE CHECKS.
WE HAVE ENHANCED UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE THAT WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE STATES.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT’S DETERMINATION TO
SUPPORT THE U.S. ECONOMY.
>> Chris: FINALLY,
MR. SECRETARY, 3.3 MILLION
PEOPLE APPLIED FOR ON EMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS THIS WEEK.
THAT IS FOUR TIMES THE PREVIOUS
HIGHEST RECORD SINCE 1967 WHEN
THESE RECORDS WERE KEPT.
FORMER HEAD OF THE CBO SAYS WE
ARE GOING TO SEE IT ON UP LIMIT
RATE IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS OF
20%.
YOUR FORMER COMPANY IS
PROJECTING THAT GDP IN THE
SECOND QUARTER INSTEAD OF BEING
UP 2% OR 3% IS GOING TO BE MINUS
24%.
IS THAT WHAT YOU’RE SEEING AT
THE TREASURY DEPARTMENT, 20%
UNEMPLOYMENT, A GDP SHRINKING
FROM YEAR-OVER-YEAR BY A
QUARTER?
>> Secretary Mnuchin: CHRIS
COBRA IS HARD TO PREDICT THESE
NUMBERS BECAUSE WE HAVEN’T HAD
ANYTHING LIKE THIS WHERE WE SHUT
ON THE U.S. ECONOMY FOR MEDICAL
REASONS.
THE ECONOMY WAS IN VERY, VERY
GOOD HEALTH AND WE SHUT IT DOWN.
AND LET ME JUST SAY WE ARE VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO THE PEOPLE WHO
DON’T HAVE JOBS AND THAT’S WHY
THE PRESIDENT WAS VERY CLEAR
THAT HE WANTED ME TO WORK WITH
CONGRESS ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS
QUICKLY TO SUPPORT THOSE PEOPLE.
SO I HOPE NUMBER ONE BUSINESSES
REHIRE, SMALL BUSINESSES REHIRE
THOSE PEOPLE NOW THAT THEY’LL
HAVE THE MONEY.
NUMBER TWO, PEOPLE WILL HAVE
ENHANCED UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE,
AND NUMBER THREE, PEOPLE WILL
HAVE DIRECT DEPOSIT MONEY IN
THEIR ACCOUNTS TO PROVIDE
LIQUIDITY.
AND WE WANT TO GET PEOPLE BACK
TO WORK AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN
SUBJECT TO THE MEDICAL
CONDITIONS.
>> Chris: UNDERSTOOD, BUT
BRIEFLY -- I’VE GOT ABOUT 30
SECONDS LEFT, YOU’RE SAYING, YOU
SEEM TO BE SAYING, THAT 20%
UNEMPLOYMENT IN GDP MINUS A
QUARTER, 24%, IS NOT IMPOSSIBLE.
MAY NOT LAST LONG, BUT WE MAY
SEE THOSE NUMBERS AND WE MAY
HAVE TO LIVE WITH THAT.
>> Secretary Mnuchin: I DON’T
KNOW WHAT THE NUMBERS ARE GOING
TO BE THIS QUARTER.
I DO THINK WE’RE GOING TO KILL
THIS VIRUS, WE’RE GOING TO
REOPEN THIS ECONOMY AND IN THE
THIRD QUARTER OF THIS YEAR
YOU’RE GOING TO SEE THIS ECONOMY
BOUNCE BACK WITH VERY LARGE GDP
NUMBERS AND LOW UNEMPLOYMENT
BACK TO WHERE WE WERE
BEFOREHAND.
THE PRESIDENT HAS DETERMINED
THAT WE PROTECT PEOPLE AND
REOPEN THE ECONOMY WHEN IT’S THE
RIGHT TIME.
>> Chris: SECRETARY MNUCHIN,
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME DURING